many have called it genocide now two
soldiers from Myanmar may have provided
the evidence needed to bring a case to
the international criminal court there
are reports that two men are in the Haag
and what could be a breakthrough in the
search for justice for the killing of
Muslim rohinga Human Rights group
fortify rights says it's been taped
confessions from Two Soldiers who say
they deserted from the Myanmar Army in
the lengthy videos the men admitted to
massacres rapes and the destruction of
ringa Villages the Rights group says
they've also named other soldiers and
Senior commanders involved in the crimes
well let's cross over to the he where
step vasson is live for us step we're
getting reports that the two men are in
at the or at least in the care of the
international criminal court they're in
the hag somewhere what more do we know
about where they are and what's
happening yes exactly we are hearing
reports that they might have arrived
here uh on Monday uh officially the
Court denies that they are in custody uh
which is uh probably uh now the case is
that they're in a witness protection
program here at the prosecutor's office
the prosecutor's office I have to
explain is independent from the court so
so far there hasn't been any arrest
warrant against these two individuals
from Myanmar uh the IC the international
criminal court has a significant
Protection Program for Witnesses so if
they are here it's very likely that the
court has helped them get a Visa uh
travel to the Netherlands and also uh
provide them with assistance during
their stay here but the prosecutor's
office says they can't confirm any of
this uh information while this
investigation is still ongoing and I
also urge everyone not to speculate
because you have to understand this is a
very sensitive case it's a it's a a
crime against humanity of course what
happened in Myanmar has been described
as genocide and this if this is true
these would be the two first uh
testimonies from people within the
military from Myanmar to come out so
there is of course a lot of concern for
the safety of these two uh people the
two former soldiers so the court and the
prosecutor's office is not confirming if
they're actually here in the hake right
now St bring us up to date with what we
know about where the case is at the
moment well the case was stuck for quite
a long time the investigation because
Myanmar is not a signatory to the the
Rome statute which is the basis of this
international criminal court uh but they
have found a way out of this last year
the court has ruled that they have
jurisdiction and they found a way
because Bangladesh is a signatory to the
uh to the Rome statute and part of the
crimes that happened in uh Myanmar uh
were happening in Bangladesh as well for
example the deportations there were lots
of forced deportations hundreds of
thousands of ethnic rohinga the minority
in uh in myanma were forcefully deported
to Bangladesh so the crossing of the
border is a fact that the court now
considers uh an event that has happened
in the country that has signed uh the
the Rome statute so that's why this case
now has uh been speeding up since last
November the court has urged
investigation to continue and if they
have these two uh former military and we
don't know exactly their their their
position but if they are uh they they
say they were involved they have uh uh
given a very detailed account of what
they did and also who was with them also
the high ranking officers then of course
this would be an enormous Boo for this
investigation St vason bringing us up to
date from the he I want to bring in
Muhammad Jam Jun because he's been
covering the rohinga crisis extensively
he's joining me now uh well one of the
things that we have to remember about
all of this is that we actually just
don't know very much there are going to
be a lot of questions about who these
men are whether or not they are actually
from myar and so on you're absolutely
right Rob and and right now we have a
lot more questions than we do answers of
course fortify rights uh is saying that
in these videos these two soldiers uh
confess two crimes uh of rape of burning
Villages and that they name senior
commanders that they go up the chain of
the tat Mada the Myanmar military uh the
those who were present when this
Crackdown was going on which started
August 25th 2017 in Rakin State against
uh the rohinga ethnic minority um but
it's really going to be interesting to
find out where exactly these soldiers
are uh in that chain um how high they
are up the chain I mean if this is
verified and if the information that
these soldiers are providing is credible
this is potentially huge this could be
something that really acts as a Catalyst
when it comes to potentially bringing
charges of genocide against Myanmar in
the international criminal court we must
remember there is a case at the
international court of justice that has
been brought by The Gambia and now uh
Canada and the Netherlands have joined
that case against Myanmar charging
Myanmar with with genocide and there
have been provisional measures ordered
by the court by the icj in that case um
you know asking myanmar's government to
make sure that evidence uh is preserved
and also uh asking uh well demanding
rather myanmar's uh government to uh to
to give them reports every six months or
so as to what is going on in rakhine
state but at the ICC where there was a a
preliminary investigation and then last
November it became an official
investigation by the prosecutor's office
uh this is really something that could
change as far as what is going on there
and how they approach a potential case
against Myanmar at the IC Rob Muhammad
as we were talking about earlier the
fact that you have covered this case
means you you have a lot of contacts
among the rohinga in Bangladesh and
elsewhere in your estimation How great
is the risk do you think that there
might be some sort of reprisal against
ringa who are still in Myanmar as a
result of this this is something that is
always on the minds uh really foremost
in the minds of rohinga refugees who are
in Bangladesh they are constantly
worried about what is going on with
their Rel relatives back in rakine state
because there still are hundreds of
thousands of rohinga in rakine state and
in fact uh you've had um un officials
and many rights organizations who have
said in the past that they are concerned
that there is an ongoing genocide being
perpetrated by myanmar's military
against the rohinga in rakine state that
means they believe that this genocide
didn't just happen in 2017 in rakine
state they believe it is happening even
today and so rohinga refugees that you
speak with in the camps are always
concerned about what might happen about
the reprisals that their relatives might
face about the fact that they don't hear
very often from their relatives because
there has been an internet shutdown for
quite some time in rakine State uh so
yes they are concerned and this is
something that they're going to be
worried about when and if they speak to
the media about these developments
because it's something that they carry
with them uh because of the trauma that
they faced when they were in rakhine
state and because of the trauma they
fear that their relatives are still
facing in rakine state Muhammad thank
you very much indeed Antonio mvy is the
executive director of legal action
worldwide now she was in Bangladesh as a
un investigator at the height of the
crisis and she's joining us live from
Aman in Jordan by Skype thank you very
much indeed for giving us your time you
saw the end result of the rhinga
refugees who were making their way to
Bangladesh as we mentioned at the height
of this crisis in your estimation if
these allegations turn out to be true
this evidence turns out to be verified
how significant is
this thank you rob well this is an
astounding turn of events um and
certainly when I was a un investigator
on the borders of Bangladesh as the
hundreds of thousands ringer pulled
across the border um we never thought
that we would be in this situation uh
the stories that I I listen to resonate
with what we have uh seen from the
testimonies of these two former me andar
soldiers that they were ordered to kill
uh indiscriminately they were ordered to
rape to gang rape brutally uh brutal
sexual violence um and since that time
uh I now represent hundreds of ringa uh
some of them are from The Villages that
these two former myamar soldiers have
talked about and I talked to them
earlier today in the camps to to gauge
their reaction to this um and what they
said was relief relief that the world
has heard uh what has happened finally
an omnition from the Myanmar Army but
also that turns to anger and to sorrow
and thinking about their loved ones and
also the ringa that still remain in
Myanmar as we were just talking about to
Muhammad Jam jum our correspondent there
one of the key elements of this at the
moment is how little we know about these
men and the the fact that one would
assume that their their stories have at
least been attempted to be checked out
and verified and so on is it an
indication of how confident the
international criminal court feels about
that evidence that we we believe these
men have been transported to the
hag well uh Rob it's hard to comment on
that and as we've heard that the ICC
will make no comment as to whether they
have them in custody but what do we know
well we've seen that their their stories
are said to be credible and corative now
indeed that also resonates from the
interviews and statements I have taken
as a lawyer representing ringa um they
talk they come from uh the tong Bazaar
and the other Villages that have been
mentioned um in the reports um of the
mass gang rape of the killing and also
indeed it stated about the clear orders
and I think this is important from
senior military commanders and whilst
they may be very uh low in the ranks um
I think we hope hope that more will come
forward and there has been shown to be a
clear chain of command and also let's
just reflect back as well to
International court of justice case
where we had on the 10th of December and
the 11th of December last year Anam sui
herself at beag defending the Myanmar
Army for their actions and there was no
admission so this is really an important
moment both for the ringa and I think
for international Justice and we hope to
see that the International Community as
a whole will be supporting this and
we've seen that Canada and Netherlands
are now joining as an intervention to
the icg case and let's hope that
there'll be more support I think for the
ringa as we know there's a crowded space
in the world with what has happened with
Co and to hear their voices and their
cries for justice help me out with an
explanation here because if I understand
it correctly the international court of
justice has is bringing a case which is
essentially broadly um aimed towards
Myanmar but the ICC has the capacity to
bring action against individuals which
may mean if I understand it correctly
that some of those uh senior members of
the military and possibly further up in
the chain whom these men have identified
may be uh individually targeted with
prosecutions is that accurate we may see
this going further up the
chain you're absolutely right Rob let's
put it simply the international court of
justice is state to state Gambia versus
Myanmar any decision will be against the
state itself it is not a criminal
prosecution against individuals the
international criminal court will be
investigating and we hope Prosecuting
individuals and now if we look at the
past um formerly the IC was actually
investigating Prosecuting lower down
soldiers but most more recently um in
their prosecutions they have gone for
senior commanders we hope that this will
be a door uh to that and of course there
have many and more numerous sanctions
against senior mil uh mear military
Antonio mavey is executive director of
legal action worldwide we appreciate
your time M thank you very much
indeed